[Music]
forty-eight seconds of logos strolling
synchronized mask lifting maybe a nice
visual flourish but seasoned criminals
put that down way before anyone gets a
chance to spot their faces also this
group of thieves are great they found
the one area in Atlanta where there
isn't any traffic that's some good high
scouting right there I was going to go
with my usual way too nitpicky
observation here but seeing the obvious
Joey in the scene put together by the
music the actor whose name I can't
pronounce and Edgar Wright I'm not gonna
sit off dry wiping we would not be
hearing this from outside the building
you see fast in the Furious this is how
you film a car doing a stunt I'm gonna
knock another sent off and retroactively
Lee add one to the Fast and Furious
franchise somehow I mean this is
probably the morning the bank was open
and there were customers in there but
we're in Atlanta can you speed to 80 at
this hour this automotive shell game is
supremely fun and clever but the chances
of two other red cars that look similar
from above with the exact same pink
color exact same Sun roofs and exact
same wear and tear happening to drive by
at just the right moment is about the
same as the chances no one in the
comments will complain that we take this
all just a tad bit too seriously sure
this might work to get one car to the
center exactly why did the other car
slow down to stay even with them that
third car would have been long gone by
the time baby got back up to speed as
they ditch this ride
surely to be found by cops later now
might be a good time to count each place
baby left a beautiful on glove
fingerprint as a gift for the police the
steering wheel the gear ship the parking
brake the rearview mirror the wiper
switch the air violin side of the
freaking car seriously look at that it's
like he's purposely printing each finger
just so the police can have a full set
this building that simulates a road with
a double yellow line up it is so clever
and beautiful it had to be mentioned but
if we stop every time Edgar Wright does
something visually clever or beautiful
we'd be here till the Avatar sequels
come out so here's a sent off for this
moment and for many moments like this to
come for black hoss news media
[Music]
four coffees in less than five seconds
movie apparently hasn't been to a coffee
shop lately I'm pretty sure barista is
Italian for it will be really when I say
it's ready see the scar it's apparently
part of baby's face except when it's not
like mere seconds ago
[Music]
baby is addicted deaf people through
some kind of magic trick Debra gets
ready for work with her hair tied back
in four seconds does she not hear this
how did she just grab his recorder and
start recording how does she know there
isn't something important already on
that tape I'm just saying my dad grabbed
a VHS to record the Tigers winning the
World Series in 84 and now my mom can't
find the tape of their wedding ceremony
coincidence yeah cute juice but solid
Seoul raised heel shoes are another type
of footwear worn by people who have jobs
that keep them on their feet all day the
drive is supposed to be the ass and it
is I just I when Doc assembles the
screws is it required to have somebody
who hates baby immediately for almost no
reason
edgar wright calls this a double oscar
shot i call it a Horrible Bosses reunion
tomato tomahto
he stole my Mercedes had a lot of
merchants it I watched him do it too I
didn't stop him though cuz I was just
blinded by the balls on that kid yeah
well considering what they're saying
about you these days I'm not surprised
this is Miss Austin Powers this is a
funny cup with the Michael Myers
Halloween mask that was part of the plan
but why are they finding out about this
just now in fact since doc is the one
setting up this heist
why didn't he already have the Michael
Myers masks the plan is so meticulously
thought-out I'm surprised doc even
allows the robbers to buy their own
masks who even is this guy we supposed
to believe he's just a bystander who
happens to have military experience who
happens to have a loaded automatic
weapon hiding in the front seat with a
safety off also even if he had time to
prep fine was the handgun still stow and
why was he parked in the back of a
parking lot like this this car seat
chest buckle is already unlatched which
means either bad job by mama or bad job
by movie we know better than to blame
mama this one's on you movie it's almost
like doc picked the dumbest crew ever
for this job how did these guys even get
recommended wait a second let me get
this straight you execute a guy for
accidentally leaving a shotgun behind
and in doing so you leave bloody
fingerprints on the car and a bloody
blanket hanging out of the trunk for any
passers-by to see I already much also
how do you not know that trunk didn't
shut even just by sound everyone knows
when a trunk is fully shut that car had
more open trunk than elephant on
antihistamines it's Debbie
Debra damnit debbie Debra have you no
boundaries
keep your hands off my recorder there is
no universe in which a pair of
standard-issue iPod headphones stretches
that far between two people except of
course the universe where a romantic
laundromat scene is needed Joseph wants
baby to get a job delivering pizzas
which is fine this is the only thing he
thinks baby can do or is this the only
mail spam Joseph gets that inspires job
opportunities whoa that was that I get
the joke that his driving skills get it
there quick but the actual drive isn't
really the part that takes a long unless
baby is also driving the oven this is
misplaced gratitude don't get me wrong
Lilly James is captivating in this movie
but her character is written with
absolutely zero agency the women in this
movie seemed to only exist in relation
to what the men need and have characters
as thin as CG Matt Damon in the last
half-hour over the Martian oh no no no
why are you telling me it's as if Edgar
Wright heard that last sin and wrote one
more line just to prove my point sheesh
so go inside take note of the number of
cameras and positions I know that doc
just showed how much power he has over
baby but does he seriously not have
anyone else who can take notes about the
post office doc made a point to say he
never uses the same crew twice but I
guess that doesn't mean he can't mix and
match from other crews from time to time
pick away buddy
darling plays the that guy game so the
buddy has to ask who the hell that guy
is together
robbed you the guy that called you a
whore the guy that looked at you funny
that's funny if buddy is so prone to
killing people after stuff like that
then why is Darlene talking about
murdering bats in front of baby
maybe we should infer that she always
asked him to do that I can't believe
she's so Cavalier to discuss it right
now just because she thinks baby won't
say anything even darling here only
exists in relationship to buddy her
tattoo literally says his for pete's
sake let's go okay so bath just killed
the convenience store clerk to steal
some gum something that would have been
easy to do without killing anyone and it
establishes once and for all that bass
is a psychopath but is he stupid too the
store has cameras and he was in that
store without a mask and while we're at
it it looks like the clickers behind
some late-night bulletproof glass or
whatever if
Batz has the capability of shooting the
clerk somehow how did nobody in the car
hear it as the smoking pigs
never mind that Baptist partners had no
idea he's going to start shooting but
once they do realize it they are
outnumbered and using handguns against
guys with automatic weapons yet the
entire crew survives does this guy doing
nobody knew he was alive and he thought
the best course of action was to make a
run for towards the people who just
killed everybody the Freeman and aren't
there plenty of cars he could have
gotten into that we're already running
so what's your real name
darling Monica okay so we were allowed
to discuss news why would darling tell
bats her real name didn't she want this
guy killed a minute ago why doesn't she
tell him Goff already that stop stop
stop
Oh in course of all the gin joints and
all the atlanta's of the world bats
wants to go into this King diner and
Debra's working at this time of night
haven't we seen her working day shifts
all this time
I guess baby has his don't talk to me or
you'll get exposed as someone I care
about which will put you in danger face
off because Debra instinctively knows
not to say anything to him as he walks
in so they go through all this just to
order some cokes don't even drink them
and leave what kind of manufacturer plot
bolt is this bat said he was super
hungry I guess now he's gonna do a
Southern tradition and hit up Waffle
House sir crystal somehow baby is able
to stop this true psycho from punching
him in the face and shooting up the
diner I disagree with this film's
portrayal of what would have actually
happened well you contacts was cops that
I know they were my cops is there any
reason why you wouldn't share that
information with your crew and another
thing if doc has these comps on the
payroll then why can't he get somebody
to just hand deliver the weapons to the
crew why set up this whole thing in the
middle of nowhere and waste everybody's
time is that true they fired first
despite everyone's body language in the
scene and terrible poker faces doc
believes the story enough to continue
with the heist
despite justified paranoia and why is
this heist so goddamn important right
now anyway it's not like the post office
or the money order is going anywhere
even if doc is convinced the police
won't figure out who killed their boys
why risk it now when you can just as
easily do it next week why would you
listen to this thing here of all places
and man that tape recorder sure is
awesome for being in his pocket and
picking up doc luck he's speaking
directly into the microphone baby who is
a world-class getaway driver who sees
every detail in front of him when he's
car only notices buddy when we notice it
discussed this oh you mean the recorder
baby would absolutely never leave out of
his possession unless it was convenient
for the block yes let's discuss that
also bats saw baby li and he thought
I'll go to his room first
trying to figure out this scenario we
saw bats wake up but the first instinct
was not to track baby down but rummage
through his room and maybe he heard baby
stupidly playing that tape recorder
earlier and knew he needed to do
something about it but maybe I'm so sure
it would still be there maybe your new
buddy was going down to catch him but
buddy seemed super surprised to see bats
show up so it doesn't appear they
coordinated this Amy your call decision
and we know this thing or not I also
love how this recorder absolutely nails
the start time on that phrase each and
every time that brain isn't that the
waitress from the diner I would believe
bats remembering this name but I'm not
buying darling remembering it bats was
the one who bothered to check out the
name tag and say the name out loud and
while the movie made a big deal out of
showing her nametag it's not like the
whole crew was paying attention that
much I'm your driver tomorrow I'm
driving okay well we'll just forget all
these tapes man that you were clearly
trying to escape earlier we can see now
that you're just a struggling musician
who knows how to drive fast so sorry for
the misunderstanding that's how bad guy
stuff works right geez baby communicates
to yet another person what he needs them
to do simply by looking at them this
postal clerk gets the entire message she
needs from a look and a head shake and
does she recognize baby from his visit
the other day despite him wearing
sunglasses and how convenient she's not
in the post office right now and is just
getting to work holy crap utility truck
parked outside a post office with
stabbing Ron's ex machina
well wait a second what button did he
just hit before sending bats to a pole
dancing lesson passenger airbag off I
could send it for thinking that somehow
the airbag would have made any
difference with his impalement but the
real sin is thinking the audience would
even know what button he pushed that
quickly
there's no way after all the fuckery
that the cops knew what's door baby was
in the guy I hopped three escalators and
totally lost them and besides even if
they knew which story was in why didn't
they have someone at the exit to prevent
an escape in the long hallowed tradition
of movie car theft baby realizes all you
need is something straight and metal to
get a car started darling would be
amazing at cinemasins good grief little
early unless the police force is now 10
feet tall or bone decided to ascend into
the trees you are aiming way too high
ever notice in a gunfight how no one can
hit anything until it's time for a
character to die and then all of a
sudden everybody becomes marksmen of the
year we do the last time we saw buddy he
was still in a shootout with the APD and
the movie cut away from it he was almost
certainly going to get shot or captured
in that parking lot but through film
Nisha he's here now like nothing
happened what diner uses the restroom
key the restrooms are open right it's an
eating establishment where restrooms are
there for easy access
oh oh oh kiss that's enough for me we
don't have a car or music
and as if on cue two druggies drive
their amazing sports car out into the
middle of nowhere to facilitate this
love story vaping is the new binding and
Apple the shot is done 100% practically
damn for you and I are a team
don't feed me any more lines from
Monsters Inc it pisses me off yeah if
you're gonna go Pixar do a bug's life
there's nothing I can do for you kid why
should I
after what you done to me wait is that a
cue to come in though I'll deal with the
cops did someone order a heart
transplant how on God's green earth did
the same guy who said this could break
your legs and tell everyone you love all
the sudden become mr. self-sacrifice I
might buy that it lets him go
but put himself in danger who he gives
no character motivation for that in the
slightest that's not the cop so buddy
knew that baby would show up to the
hideout what gave him that idea the
script there's no way he thinks doc
would be okay with baby showing up here
car survives this okay two things here
either he got out and baby should have
seen it
or he didn't get out and he should be
dead there's no scenario by which buddy
gets out of this and is able to get the
drop on baby but that's what the movies
gonna tell us villain won't die cliche
movie continues to be kind of baby
whenever he needs to escape a situation
just a reminder none of the bullets that
made any of those bullet holes even
grazed either of our leads through my
purse right at me and he actually said
I'm sorry
you mean after he put a gun to your head
and stole your car yeah seems like a
great guy let's take some years off the
sentence for a little apologetic purse
sorry
I hereby students to defend it to 25
years in the federal penitentiary
subject to a parole hearing after five
years served no just now the minimum
sentence for armed robbery in Georgia is
10 years without parole and that's per
offense which the movie has reminded us
is a lot and two that if someone is
killed it's an automatic life sentence
whether you do the killing or not with
the earliest parole being 30 years
pull to the I don't want to go in there
and sucks think of a place that's really
perfect your own happy place nobody puts
Baby
you got 30 seconds asshole you buddy
hello hello this killers are
first-timers you want to pull off a
brilliant murder you got to act like
it's an accident if you do it right you
ain't even gotta be there when it goes
down I use a head detective if so you
are probably the last man standing
you need to sunset that ride we're going
to a place called monster Joe's truck
and tow no monster Jonah's daughter
Raquel is sympathetic to our dilemma